foreign
good afternoon everyone my name is Dr
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is
scp-3627 object class Euclid
special containment procedures
scp-3627 is to be contained in a
standard non-humanoid holding cell at
site this paragraph Was stricken from
the document
scp-3627 is to be kept in a soundproof
containment cell under constant video
surveillance any recorded instances of
unprompted anomalous behavior on the
part of scp-3627 are to be reported to a
supervisor of level 3 clearance or
higher
description
scp-3627 is a children's music box
approximately 23 by 15 by 8 centimeters
in size the word acrobats is written on
the front of scp-3627 below which is a
glass casing containing two acrobat
figurines connected at the hands to a
rotating axle at the base of scp-3627 is
a small compartment with the phrase
dreamy Jesters written in faded paint no
company or manufacturing labels are
present on scp-3627 and attempts to
identify the origins of
scp-3627 have been unsuccessful
the anomalous properties of scp-3627
manifest when a human inserts an object
into
scp-3627's base compartment objects
inserted by non-human entities have not
triggered any anomalous phenomena upon
the insertion of an object and the
closing of the compartment the two
acrobat figurines within scp-3627 will
rotate around the central axle and a
series of chime-like sounds will be
produced the exact pattern of these
sounds varies depending on the object
inserted and the individual performing
the insertion a single iteration of the
pattern will generally last between 5 to
15 seconds and will repeat for a period
between 4 and 8 hours attempts to open
the compartment door during this process
using conventional means have been met
with failure
subjects who have experienced the
effects of
scp-3627 report Vivid and emotionally
charged dreams although the contents of
these dreams vary widely between
instances certain similarities are
always present
number one dreams invoked by
scp-3627 always exhibits some relation
to the inserted object whether it be
directly through the literal presence of
the object in the dream or indirectly
through an idea or an experience that
the subject Associates with the object
number two despite the frequent presence
of disturbing content Within These
Dreams subjects will ultimately view
them as a positive experience and will
feel a sense of peace upon Awakening
and number three subjects who experience
dreams invoked by
scp-3627 will lose any prior attachments
to the inserted object as well as any
personal or abstract Concepts associated
with said object
this is the only known permanent
defective scp-3627
upon the conclusion of the musical
pattern the object formally inserted
into
scp-3627 will no longer be present
within the compartment the location of
the inserted objects following their
disappearance is currently unknown in
place of the object will be a six by six
centimeter segment of paper containing a
typed note
notes delivered by
scp-3627r generally between 6 and 12
lines long and are Loosely formatted in
iambic pentameter which has been
stricken from the document see addendum
3627 3 with an alternating rhyme scheme
while these notes are generally only
produced after the insertion of an
object and the completion of
scp-3627's auditory process the
appearance of a note without the
occurrence of these events has been
observed on two occasions previously one
the notes themselves are non-anomalous
in their physical composition however
the written contents of the notes
indicate a level of sentience on the
part of
scp-3627 the notes are always directed
at the subject who most recently
experienced
scp-3627 auditory effects and generally
provide cryptic analysis and advice
regarding their relation to the inserted
object see addendum 3627 2 for more
information
scp-3627 always uses plural pronouns
when referring to itself within these
notes suggesting that multiple entities
may be responsible for
scp-3627's effect
scp-3627 will occasionally reference its
SCP status and its current location
within Foundation custody as well as
knowledge of other scps and Foundation
activities
scp-3627's level of knowledge regarding
the foundation is currently unknown as
is its means of accessing said knowledge
addendum 3627 1. initial discovery
scp-3627 was discovered by agent during
a routine Thrift Shop sweeping Montana
upon inspection
scp-3627 produced The Following note no
objects were inserted prior to the
production of this message and no
auditory phenomena were observed
hello agent it seems you found an object
that is worth being secured contained
and yes protected through its sound a
wondrous tune that you have not yet
heard just place a gift into our waiting
grasp a memory that haunts your waking
mind
and in return We Shall relax the clasp
that keeps it within your soul so
intertwined
your line of work is filled with those
who need the closure and peace that we
bestow bring those that are Desiring of
this deed release the pain and help them
to let go
upon realizing the note contained
obvious allusions to the foundation
agent purchased the object and delivered
it to containment Personnel at site
addendum 3627 2 experiment logs
the following experiments detail the
effects of
scp-3627 on certain individuals upon the
insertion of certain objects information
pertaining to the psychological and
personal history of the subjects has
been included as it is believed to be
pertinent to the resultant effects of
scp-3627
experiment 3627 a subject d2213
inserted object wedding ring belonging
to subject t2213
information of note subject's husband
died in an automobile accident four
months prior to Foundation recruitment
psychiatric testing has revealed some
severe emotional trauma resulting from
this event
results subject recalled dreaming of her
wedding day the dream was identical to
her memories of her actual wedding day
with the exception of the groom who was
motionless throughout the ceremony and
appeared to be in an advanced State of
Decay neither the subject nor anyone
else attending the ceremony were
bothered by this upon being instructed
to kiss the bride the subject recalled
the transfer of a warm viscous sand
malodorous fluid from the groom's mouth
into her own subject was once again
unfazed and swallowed the entirety of
the fluid produced
recalling that It produced a warm
comforting feeling inside her
following this exchange the groom
disappeared and was absent for the
duration of the ceremony
subject awoke shortly after cutting into
the wedding cake
upon Awakening the subject was
unbothered by The Disappearance of her
wedding ring subject reported a strong
sense of closure regarding the death of
her husband stating that I know he'll
always be a part of me and that he would
want me to move on
long-term psychiatric analysis has
confirmed a notable Improvement in the
subject's mental health
the note produced by
scp-3627 following this experiment is as
follows
no pain is like the bondage of Two Souls
detached by cruel and unforgiving fate
but true pain is when one's own grief
controls the life that Still Remains
under its weight we cannot say for sure
if you will meet again on a distant
Rising Dawn but if your memories are
still complete your love of soul is
never truly gone
experiment 3627 B
subject
d-4256
inserted object standard number two
pencil
information of note subject enjoys
drawing as a recreational Hobby
results subject recall dreaming of a
windowless prick room lit by a single
incandescent light bulb the room bore a
heavy resemblance to the basement of the
subject's childhood home subject
recalled frantically scribbling on
dozens of sheets of paper and taping
them to the left wall of the room once
finished the scribblings formed the
shape of a humanoid figure the humanoid
figure then emerged from the papers and
became a three-dimensional being
resembling the subject although slight
differences in facial structure subject
then recalled being assaulted by the
figure and pressed against the wall
causing him to become a two-dimensional
being confined to the papers subject at
this point entered an omniscient point
of view as he saw the figure exit the
room through a previously non-existent
door which led into the street of a
Suburban neighborhood
at this point the passage of time
appeared to increase in rate as houses
on either side of the street gradually
decayed and were overgrown by plant life
the figure was seemingly unaffected by
this process and stood motionlessly in
the street after several minutes the
passage of time returned to a normal
rate and a mushroom cloud indicative of
a nuclear detonation appeared in the
distance subject awoke shortly after
watching the figure slowly melt in the
street and detecting a strong odor of
burning paper
upon Awakening the subject showed little
interest in drawing subject displays no
displeasure toward drawing and was able
to draw upon instruction with the same
level of skill as before but stated that
he just didn't feel any desire to do it
anymore
to date the subject is still not
partaken in drawing or any other visual
artistic medium without being instructed
to do so
the note produced by
scp-3627 following this experiment is as
follows
everyone's Mark Forever on the earth is
strived for through whatever means one
cow create a piece of true artistic
wealth alas the subtle marks upon one's
Soul cannot be cloned by any moral hands
alive is better lived when Jordan Hall
then stretched across the ever shifting
Sands
experiment 3627 C
subject doctor
inserted object video recording device
remotely connected to a viewing monitor
information of note experiment aims to
observe the destination of objects
inserted into
scp-3627 Dr head of scp-3627
experimentation performed the insertion
in order to gain a better idea of the
dreaming process
results subject recalled dreaming of a
hallway located in a foundation
containment facility similar to site the
hallway was lined with containment cells
containing numerous scps subjects
specifically recalled seeing SCP SCP SCP
and SCP despite none of these scps being
stored in the same facility in reality
the subject recalls being suddenly
overwhelmed by a feeling of dread and
sprinting through multiple corridors in
an attempt to exit the facility the
layout of the building was nonsensical
and labyrinthine containing multiple
unnecessary loops and dead ends upon
locating the exit the subject ran
several hundred meters from the facility
before gaining enough composure to look
back the facility was several hundred
times larger than any active Foundation
site and had the same approximate
Dimensions as a human heart the outside
of the building was lined with several
thousand containment cells each contain
in SCP the facility began to beat at
regular intervals sending Tremors
through the surrounding area subject
were called losing balance from the
force of the vibrations the Tremors
slowly increased in magnitude until the
surrounding land shattered and the
subject was left falling through a black
swirling void subject awoke shortly
thereafter
upon Awakening subject destroyed all
video footage received from the inserted
recording device stating that some
things are better left unexplained
subject later submitted a formal
resignation was administered amnestics
and released
the note produced by
scp-3627 following this experiment is as
follows
the humans
curiosity is what puts them above the
animals but there are things that a man
should best not see that can't be kept
within Foundation walls the tortured
minds of ancient Horrors shriek their
coals can shred the Earth and tear the
skies if their secrets you do persist to
seek then you're seeking your very own
demise
further experimentation on
scp-3627 has been discontinued
indefinitely
addendum 3627-3 incident report
20 on 20 87 days after experimentation
on
scp-3627 was discontinued
scp-3627 produced a pattern of tones
without the prior insertion of an object
these tones could be heard outside of
scp-3627's holding cell and caused two
d-class Personnel to fall unconscious
this was the first instance of
scp-3627 invoking REM sleep in multiple
individuals at once the pattern of tones
was repeated for 2 minutes and 34
seconds a notably shorter duration than
those previously observed
upon the conclusion of the pattern both
subjects awoke and immediately attempted
to access the holding cell containing
scp-3627 first by attempting to guess
the access code then by repeatedly
ramming into the cell their activity was
eventually detected by the on-site
security system and armed Foundation
Personnel were dispatched to the area
both subjects were successfully
terminated before causing a Containment
Breach
scp-3627's containment procedures have
been updated accordingly
the following note was found within
scp-3627 shortly after the incident
we revealed ourselves to you
so that you would take us in
we did this because we knew you had no
short supply of sin we thought we'd help
you to let go
is the guilt and help you heal
but we were fools for now we know that
you have no guilt that you could feel
you really think you're going good with
all that you collect but then again of
course you would
secure contain protect
[Music]
I think that about does it for today
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you're all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to
big sip
Timothy
zargaron
the Morrigan
James Saba
oh crop guy
heroin sick
Cassie 11.
fire of prime
and D versus the world
Spencer arduin
rubbish Ben 69
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
worthy fire
zazapan
Lemke
signor
alatreon
your local Foundation agent
derivative
Lost Boy
and Lyndon B Johnson
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you